hey let's do it again
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your favorite podcast
hey you know
[Music]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
okay all right we did it
you know we're with griffin the one-man
show so i gotta do the music i gotta
turn the music on i gotta put the
singing mic down i gotta do all this
stuff but welcome back to whiffenwick
griffin i really appreciate you guys
being here each week
you know i like my little crowd you know
i mean you're not little still
thousands of people right but you know
in comparison to like you know
you know you see these other podcasts
you're like oh i wish i had these
numbers but
i'm not i love these numbers too i love
all you guys that keep coming back
every week and i'm trying to grow and
i'm still doing the thing that i do and
here's here we are
i'm trying to do things all the time or
i think i'm trying new things all the
time and
i don't like it i don't i take it away
but anyways we're back and remember you
can catch me
every day on twitch at eric
griffin gaming so check that out eric
griffin gaming on twitch
and in december i'm hosting a show on
twitch called potluck
with the lovely lisa malambri and it's
about
all the different types of things on
twitch other than gaming like we got
asmr there's cooking there's like
cooking competitions there's people that
make
music and they come on our show like a
little talk show and we like
expose uh the crown channel audience
to all these different things that they
have going on on twitch so make sure you
check that out that's on the crown
channel on twitch
and that's wednesdays in december i'm
the host of that it's called potluck
so uh make sure you guys uh check that
out
i'm gonna try to keep my mouth away from
the mic as much as you know try to
because i
i got sinus issues and somebody sent me
a message like eric drink some water
you're making some noise with your mouth
and i can't listen to it on my
headphones because it annoys me
i don't know man i'm old ass man now
look at this beard i'm trying to do i'm
trying to do what i do
so but anyways welcome to riffing with
griffin
i'm in mid-moving right now today i was
help i was packing and stuff because
next week at this time i will be in my
new spot
so it's a lot to get everything when
you're whole i've been living at this
place i'm at now for a while now
so you got all your things you know when
you're moving is when you really start
to realize what you need and don't need
so
i i get things and i throwing them away
and
you know i'm trying to do that maria
conda thing i don't know if you guys
know who that is it's this like little
hippie asian lady
and she she helps people
organize she has a show on netflix but
she's been around for a long time she
has a book that she wrote
but she's just all about like
appreciating the things that you have
and
you know so you know you let things go
with love it's like thank you for all
the joy you brought me but i got to let
you go to like you know that
t-shirt that you got at a concert so
many years ago like i have things that
i'm looking at like i have posters from
like
shows i did in little [ __ ] towns in
america someplace so you know it's a
little podunk town and i have the poster
that they made and i thought oh that's
so cool that i played
such and such town and i see this poster
now and i go what am i doing with this
i didn't frame it i didn't really take
care of it so i have a lot of things
like that that i've just gotten rid of
so i'm in this and just
the point right now where i'm like all
right i'm almost done with all my stuff
and then i see it and i'm like actually
i don't have a lot of stuff you know
so i'm looking forward to this move and
it's a nicer place i can't wait to do my
cooking show on my nicer place and
rachel's excited because she hates this
place so
and i've been here a long time it's time
to move on so the movie has been good
what else has been going on that i
wanted to talk about you know i talked
about covert we talked about covet a lot
i mean i know we're all coveted out but
you know it's funny the things that i've
been talking about for weeks and weeks
now just
asking about justifying you know based
off the numbers and all this stuff and
it's like getting really bad
in terms of like the numbers of people
with the outbreak but i just want to
make something clear to everybody
there's a difference between not
straining the hospital system
uh what i mean by that is like looking
out for the hospital system make sure we
have enough beds for people that need it
not just people with kovid just you know
there's regular [ __ ] that goes on all
the time people get sick and they need
to get in accidents and they need
beds to in hospitals so we got to make
sure we have beds available and that was
the main reason that we
shut down in the beginning because we
wanted to make sure we didn't overrun
the hospital system so
not overrunning the hospital system
and the severity of how covet is
affecting
you know the nation in terms of the
numbers
those aren't the same thing they're not
the same thing
to me and right now we have to take
extra
precautions because we're starting to
see it now that we're overrunning the
hospital system
and you know i'm starting to see that i
see all these news reports and because i
always used to say like
where where they always said you know
where are all these people in mass
numbers getting covered
at the hospital you don't see it but now
you're starting to see it
you know since the opening up and all
this stuff and you know uh people not
wearing masks
excuse me and all the things that people
are you know whatever people's feelings
are about it
and so now you're starting to see that
so i am a proponent of like hey
we got to make sure that our front line
workers are the the doctors and nurses
and
that they're not overrun and that we
have hospital beds for people that
really need it
so if if because like people
are recovering from covid more than they
are dying
by a large number and they're also
we're also doing way better in terms of
the mortality rate but people are still
getting it
and and some people that do get it they
get really sick and they need
medical attention so guys you know let's
you know be safe you know i just i'm so
tired of these people that are like with
their masks and like these people that
don't believe in science i just i just
don't get it
what does it hurt but the science like
all the best scientists are saying
wear a mask it does help it's like
i saw this article about this restaurant
where the guy was like he had a no mask
policy
you don't wear a restaurant on my mac
it's like so then why don't you also
undercook the chicken
you know so you know yeah the chicken's
red oh you know why you don't do that
because science says that you can't have
raw chicken and makes you sick
but you're one of these people that you
don't believe in science so
you can have anything you want in your
place like you know if somebody said you
hate this chicken ain't cooked right
you're not gonna you're not gonna be
like well that chicken looks fine to me
you're gonna be like oh you know i know
why i need to cook this chicken because
if you get sick you're gonna sue me or
whatever you know whatever
the science behind it it's like people
use science
willy-nilly when they wanted when you
know so i don't know
i just it's like i'm just so tired of
like having arguments with
anti-masters or you know i'm an
anti-massacre in a sense of like i hate
wearing it but i wear it just like you
know i don't like wear seat belts it's
tight you know especially when you're
fat you know what i mean a seat belt cut
into you but you know
it makes you safe and then with a mask
you're making other people safe is
really what it is too
it's like the dentist wears a mask not
just to protect them from
your breath or whatever so they don't
infect you they're looking in your mouth
your mouth is open
doctors wear gloves and masks so you
don't get an infection when you're on
the operating table
they wash their hands so you don't get
sick that's why they do all that kind of
stuff
it's not just for you is for our loved
ones and people around us and our you
know
you know everybody out here so do that
and then they had the big news is the uh
the vaccine
so they you know it's 95
effective and in in one set of people
94 in others you know what i found
interesting it's
100 effective in black people
i thought that was and it's crazy
because
all my black friends you know and
[Music]
some people in my in my family that i
still keep in contact with you know
they're like
these are the kind of people that don't
want to take vaccines they're like i
ain't taking no vaccine
you know what i mean but it's like the
only group that it's
100 effective according to like whatever
article i saw
you know so it's like
i talked to my buddy ian edwards you
know ian funny i just got off the phone
with him and ian was like you know i
ain't taking it right away
you know you don't you don't you i
didn't want the first iphone that's how
he said it to me and i was just like
you know there's people like that so you
know but i'm not going to tell you
something right now man
it's one thing to argue with
anti-masters one thing to argue with
someone like you know
you get into these arguments about covet
all the time with people it's people who
think it's like this most serious thing
ever and there's other people who are
like
it's a hoax or and you have all these
people that are in between you know
and you get into arguments with them
about should you wear a mask did you not
wear a mask
what's the safety of it and it's all
anecdotal actually too in terms of like
how people feel about covid i mean let's
be real about that you know it's like
if you have someone in your immediate
family that has died
you know someone personally that has
died from covet or you've been to
you know you've been to a funeral here
it's personally touched you
i don't know a lot of people that has
personally touched them in terms of
death
i don't know one person personally that
has died from covet
i know people who know people uh i you
know i
you hear about a comic or two i've heard
and i go i never met that guy
so it's touched my you know uh a
professional circle
but i don't know anyone okay and i think
that you know
that doesn't mean that i shouldn't be
safe or whatever i'm just trying to tell
you
i understand how people feel why people
have certain feelings about it because
you don't know i tell you what but i
know a lot of people
in my immediate circle like one degree
of separation friends
who have gotten covet and have gotten
over it and are fine
so if you know a lot of people like that
and then you're then you're sitting here
going like why are the restaurants still
shut down why am i why am i out of work
still
you know i just i saw uh what bill gates
said oh we should close everything down
for
until you know we shouldn't go to bars
and restaurants till 2022
what [ __ ] what hey are you gonna pass
out some of those
billions that you got in the bank like
these rich [ __ ] who think like
here's what you should do yeah you're
gonna be sitting in a palace with
servants and [ __ ]
for two years while we out here
struggling you know what i mean and
and uh and and there's people watching
my podcast who are like what are you
talking about griffin
you're gonna be doing better than me so
i totally get it like you know it's like
we gotta know how this affects people's
lives and it's like for him to say
something like that it's like
it'd be great if he was like look
everybody's gonna be struggling
and so i'm i'm getting my my all my one
percenters that i
know that that have billions of dollars
in the bank
we're gonna now help all the companies
that we work for
we're gonna pay everybody's salary for
two years you know we're gonna we're
gonna take a l
and we're gonna pay everybody's salary
for two years you know
are they gonna do that no they're not
you know the rich gonna keep getting
richer you know they got
you know and they're the ones telling us
how we're supposed to act and
we're out here struggling so anyways
how people feel about the virus is very
anecdotal in terms of like
in terms of like what it means to them
personally and that sets their mind
frame
their state of mind of of like how they
feel about it so
but look all i'm trying to say is let's
be safe
let's be as safe as possible i'm glad
this via this vaccine is coming out
i'm gonna take it like again what i was
trying to get into is like i'm not gonna
argue with people about the vaccine
because that shit's crazy
like like all the vaccine stuff has been
debunked if you want these people to
believe
vaccines give people autism get out of
my face i don't i'm
i'm not going to engage in arguments
with people with the vaccine like like i
did with like covet or like with the
masks and stuff
if you don't want to take the vaccine
keep that [ __ ] to yourself i don't care
because it just because it won't matter
to me because i'm going to take it i'm
going to be fine i'm going to move on my
life you haven't taken it so if you get
it that's on you
you made your choice but but i'm not
going to engage in this back and forth
like well
like i'm not a conspiracy theorist like
that you know what i mean listen
i i hope the best of it i hope the best
of people i hope the people that like
like i was watching this show uh on
amazon it's a old uh
british show it's called utopia and in
the uh
john cusack is a star but it's about
this company you know
and they're these kind of like co it's
like a cult
and they want the best for the world but
they go about it the wrong way obviously
it's
those are always a good story it's
people that have good intentions that go
down the wrong path you know
and so they have this whole thing where
there's this killer virus
and they come up with this vaccine but
the actual the vaccine actually is
was to like neuter everybody so they can
make the population go down so so they
they were going to put out a vaccine
where
you know no one could get pregnant for
like
five six seven years and they said
that's how we'll save the planet so that
was their plan but they were going to do
it in a horrible way
so yeah you know you have conspiracy
theorists about you know the vaccine and
that's what people think you know they
think well
it's giving people autism it's uh you
know i don't i don't take anything the
government gives me
it's like well i mean come on you know
what i mean i don't believe like that i
think the best and i think that
this is something that is important and
a lot of scientists have been working on
this and i'm just i'm just hoping for
the best so
i'm not going to engage in hyper you
know in all your nonsense about like you
know
you you know you think that this is the
illuminati trying to kill us all
you know what i mean like it's like come
on you know so
take it or not and then here's another
thing too i'm not like
wearing a mask and not wearing a mask
that that's already proven that
you know it's safer to wear a mask and
not spreading the disease and the virus
and all that but when it comes to taking
the vaccine
you can keep your [ __ ] to yourself
because you're not going to get on me
because if you're taking it take it then
you don't got to worry
okay if i don't take it don't worry
about if i don't take it you just take
it
that's how i'm going to be too i'm going
to take it and i'm not going to worry
about if you take it or not because i
know i'm going to be cool
that's even more than the the mask
situation
so let's hope that let's hope that this
vaccine
rolls out it's not going to be smooth
it's going to be crazy
there's over 300 million people in the
country it's not going to be like
until they can get it at cvs where it's
like you know covet cold and flu
or whatever where you could just go down
like they can put it in happy meals
until until it's like that easy
accessible it's going to be a
issue a situation so let's get it to the
old people let's get to the front line
workers let's get it to doctors and
nurses and
and those kind of people medical people
let's get it to the military let's get
it to the older people
and then you know we'll trickle it down
to like you know who needs it the most
and then hopefully in in two years we
will look back and remember when we
couldn't go to restaurants remember when
we were all acting crazy so
excuse me i hope for the best of all
that rambling i hope for the best
you know what i mean what else is going
on in the world
you know what i want to talk about is
like and this isn't guys
this isn't politics right now okay
because i know i get sick of talking
about politics too
and people you know if you watch my
podcast regularly you know
i i don't take one side or the other
like i'm not like
some right i'm not a right wing or a
left wing type person i'm very in the
middle
i'm s and i like to be reasonable about
my thoughts you know
so just to get some election talk for a
second so we're knee-deep in this right
now
trump had all these lawsuits he's trying
to overturn the election he's trying to
under to me
it's undermining democracy what he's
trying to do but let's say they actually
believe that the election was stolen
and there are people out there who
believe this this because of the
rhetoric
rhetoric basically that the one side is
putting out
but it is a testament to our system
because we have a system of laws and
rules
and justice we have a system in place
where it's innocent until proven guilty
we have a system in place that we have
oversight where we have the judicial
system and we have
all these laws and rules in place
to me it is a sign that it is
working when this case has gone all the
way to the supreme court
and the supreme court by the way that is
now republican dominated
you know people elected by trump and
everybody's worried about this
the fact that they have and i think that
it's a shame that we challenge the
integrity of the highest
level you know yes they might have their
leanings
okay but to me for them to get to that
point all the things you have to do you
have to be a lawyer a paralegal first a
lawyer and all
whatever you are you know whatever the
law process to get all the way to become
a judge
to get to the highest court in the land
i would hope that these people are of
the highest integrity
and intelligence and they can make an
informed choice
that is right you know like they're not
going to overturn world world versus
wade you know what i mean
they're not gonna they're not they
weren't just gonna give trump the
election they actually threw out his
case they said get this
get this [ __ ] case out of here man
and to me
that was a testament to the system
working when
a bunch of republican judges too said
man stop it you're undermining our
democracy with this nonsense
when you know that is a sign that the
system
works and i think we should be proud in
this moment
i think we should be proud as americans
that
through this and i understand the guy
don't want to leave office he's doing
all he can to stay in office okay
he's trying he's throwing and to know
that someone like that can just throw
everything at it to try to try to win
the election to try to steal it
basically you know
for him to do all that and then for the
courts to go okay you had your shot it
didn't we don't like it stop it it
didn't work you didn't win bro move on
i think that's a proud moment for the
united states
it's in our darkest times how we handle
adversity
that is a testament of being
a true great and powerful democracy
and so i i like regardless of you voted
for trump or not or if you're
pro-biden or against trump or against
biden all that
we have to we have to know that
we could take a side and the system will
make sure
we're doing the right thing now i know
there's people watching who think
that the 10 million the million there's
millions of votes and trump should have
won
i don't believe that i think that like
even even in these republican
states they're coming out and saying our
election was run
fairly and we did our job and we made
sure was accurate
you know of course there's always going
to be some some some uh
you know tomfoolery going on there's
always going to be some nonsense
you know because we're human beings
human beings are selfish and greedy and
you know what i mean so there's always
going to be people trying to to do
something bad
but at least we have this system of
checks and balances and even the
republican places were like nah this
just ain't right so
you know texas trying to sue and i just
it's like good
you try to sue and then these people
said
no this is stupid we're moving on from
this so
i just think that's a proud moment in
history for me
so congratulations on
congratulations america you know in the
united states let's let's see what
happens let's
get let's get biden in and move on trump
wants to come back in four years he can
you know apparently that you could do
that you get eight years
total so he can get his [ __ ] together
and come back and run again and you
people that support him because he you
know
he could win again he actually could i
could see him winning
you know he can learn from his mistakes
and figure things out
he's he got a lot of votes people he got
over 70 million votes that's a lot of
people to like him
so we'll see but for now let's just
respect the system
and move the hell on
so yeah that's uh
what i wanted to say about that okay
what else is going on um you know i've
been watching uh
the mandalorian on uh disney channel
i don't know if you have disney uh the
mandalorian finally came out it's only
eight episodes it's the best thing on
the disney plus
i mean other than like if you want to
watch the avengers and all those stuff
you want to watch all the old movies i
love all that stuff i love watching
aladdin and breeding the bees i love the
cartoons and all that
but at the same time like this is a
streaming platform you got to pay
monthly for
so you know give me some new content and
then you find out all those other shows
are not going to be on anymore all those
avengers shows and all that stuff i
don't know where that content is but
it's not coming on
but but i tell you it's worth having
just for mandalorian i love that show
but by the way i'm not even they're not
even my sponsor so i'm just talking
i'm just letting you know i'm giving you
my suggestion if you want to get a
streaming service i would get disney
plus
but i would only get it get it if you
bundle it because you get espn
hulu and disney plus you get uh
you get all three of those and it's
worth doing i'm just telling you right
now it's worth
because hulu by itself is totally worth
it i love hulu
cause hula you get to watch all those
network shows from certain networks like
fox
cbs there's certain networks that if you
you know you don't even need cable
you know like that's another thing too
is i can't get cable at my new spot
so i'm gonna go i'm trying all these new
tv things so my first one i'm going to
try is youtube tv
because i want to get to youtube tv is
only the there's only a few of them that
have the nfl red zone channel and i want
nfl red zone channel and youtube tv is
the one that you could get it so i'm
going to try youtube tv with it because
i get some
uh some real fast internet at the new
place so i'm so i'm not i'm getting rid
of cable
and i'm gonna try it like that but hulu
i'll tell you hulu's great
you know i love hulu so if you have hula
and then if you like espn if you're a
sports guy you get that and it's
it's all it's only like a dot like let's
say you have hulu
and you get to commercial free hulu it's
only a dollar more
and you get disney plus and espn so it's
totally worth it so
that's my suggestion to you if you want
to if you had if you asked me erica
is it worth getting dc plus it is if you
do it the way i just said
and by the way before i even get into
mandalorian i saw this great movie
last night on hulu it's called run oh
man let me see who's in this
i got i gotta i gotta get sarah paulson
that's her name
is that her name yeah wait wait wait
wait let me let me look it up one man
show i don't have a jaime
run uh movie here we go
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
sorry sarah paulson and this young
actress keira allen
oh man there's not even a lot of people
in the movie
it's really sarah paulson and this girl
the whole movie and okay so she's a mom
sarah paulson play is a mom
and and she has this like handicapped
daughter like she the girl's got
heart problems and asthma and her she's
in a wheelchair because her legs don't
work
and the movie as a movie uh you know you
reveal
you find out that the mom has this big
secret i don't want to tell you to i
don't want to take this big spoiler but
it's totally worth it it's creepy it's
one of these creepy psychological
and it's so good it's just some of the
choices that the director made like
you know them like the girl
she's like handicapped and whatever you
know so but and the mom
she's a shut-in like the mom the girl
doesn't get to leave the house
right but she's smart and she wants to
go to college and she applied for
college
and she's uh waiting for her acceptance
letter and the mom's all like
don't if the acceptance letter come
you're gonna be the first person to open
it i promise you
so they keep showing the mailman coming
up in the movie right and the girl's
like with a wheelchair she's like i
gotta go see what's going on right
and then like the mom all of a sudden
it's right there she's got the mail and
she's like no it's not here honey look
so there's this great scene where like
you know the mailman comes
and the girl's going and then the door
flies open and it's the mom right and
she's got the mail
but the door the camera pans over to the
car
and the car door is like open you know
and it implied that the mom ran from the
car
over to the uh the thing and just the
way that that
imagery this that shot it it said a lot
without saying a lot you know
so it was a well-made movie i highly
recommend watching it it's on hulu
run with sarah paulson she's from uh
she's she's always an american horror
story and she's seen her in a bunch of
things
she's actually playing a lot of like
creepy characters lately but this one is
great so i do recommend that but anyways
back to uh
the mandalorian love love
love me some mandalorian i've talked
about it before but let's talk about it
again who cares cause maybe your first
time to the podcast all right but let me
tell you one of the things i love about
the mandalorian i might
be repeating myself from a previous
podcast but like i said i don't care
so one of the things
it's shot it's shot so well
like you believe the world you know you
believe the tension the
music uh the angles and the performances
like the thing is the guy uh
let me let me let me let me look up the
i want to see because i want to see the
guy's name
oh man delorean and delorean
two series yes cast
ah pedro pascal pedro pascal plays
mandal amanda
you know he's so good
this dude is so good and you never see
his face
but i believe
what's happening i i can't explain
how emotionally invested i get in the
mandalorian
each story the things that are going on
on the show
now one of the like i said one of the
things i really love about it is
they're using a lot of cgi but the way
they make you
not actually notice the cgi
is they use puppets like the baby yoda
okay which we know his name now i forgot
i forgot it already
i like calling baby yoda he's a puppet
it's clearly a puppet
it looked like a puppet you just go why
the hell they're using this puppet
but because they use this puppet
there's something about that that draws
you in
but then also what it does is it makes
you forget about
all this other cgi that you're seeing
because it's fooling you because you're
like well this isn't real
so because that's not real and it
because they're using a puppet for that
you could totally tell it's a puppet
well that means all this other stuff is
real like it's like it's a trick in your
in the back of your head you know what i
mean
anyway i love that choice using the
puppet but you really
feel this emotional connection between
this puppet and the gu and the guy
playing
mando you know you you you feel it
you know and then like it's like he's
this great hero
too he he always wins you know what i
mean he's a great fighter and he's got
and he's got
honor you know he's an honorable
[ __ ]
you know what i mean he has this code
and
oh and one of the one things i love
about this season is like so you know he
he meets other man
other mandalorians and then like you
know like this is the way
so when he went met with it when you
first see the mandalorians you see the
other ones
they are zealots man they are like
hardcore
monk level commitment to
the mandalorian way then you meet these
other ones
and then you realize oh his group
they actually might be in the wrong they
might be like
too extreme you know like maybe he can't
take his damn mask off you don't got to
be so but he's
but you believe he's playing it so well
that with his voice acting that you just
you believe this dude right so i love it
every single story is great
you know like they're all self-contained
in a way like there's always some little
adventure that he goes on
uh the b story and that particular thing
that carries you through and i love it
man it's been great and then bill burr
made another great appearance he was
great
it's funny to see billboard because he
feels so modern
you know he feels like he's from our
world
if that makes any sense you know so it's
like when you hear about
the way he talks you know you're in your
mind you're like we're in star wars
universe do you talk like that like
where are the people that you know
from boston you know what i mean that
talk like that in the star wars world
you know what i mean so you wonder like
what world is that that he's from and
we're like oh he's from boston
you know what i mean it's just it's so
he brings that sort of like
groundedness of like oh you know he's
from earth you know what i mean it's
just funny to me
but he was great this last episode he
had a great little
thing there so i do recommend you
watching you know just even just for
bill burr
um but i love it i love like i said i
love how it's filmed
to me this is some of the best work in
the whole star wars franchise
in the whole genre i'm talking about
cartoons tv shows
movies this is some of the best star
wars work
and i hope they continue it like i
really do i hope i hope
to me i hope the people that make this
story
make other stories john favreau and all
those guys because they're part of the
avengers people you know
they're the ones that started it off you
know like they made you know
iron man you know and they started off
this whole avengers
marvel universe 17 year whatever 11 12
years ago
so i hope they do the same thing in the
star wars universe because it's totally
worth watching
it's a really really good show so i
highly recommend
you guys watch uh the mandalorian so
that's that
so now we're gonna get into real world
advice from a grown ass man and and
i got my ipad here now because um you
know i
every time i do this and i don't i want
to say i appreciate everybody like
hitting me up i get a lot of great
questions i get a lot of like i really
feel like i'm sharing
myself with you my audience when
especially when you send me all these
really questions a lot of great
questions a lot of personal questions i
try to get to
i try to get to them all but i can't so
i'll answer some of them on instagram
and then i have a few that i put on the
show
but i do appreciate you guys trying to
you know
just connect with me and me giving me a
little giving you a little nugs of
wisdom that i have from from the world
but listen i'm no expert
and sometimes i get some questions that
i go oh man this person really needs
some help
and i always encourage you to go get
some therapy and i think because i've
been doing that i now have a new sponsor
of the show
so my new sponsor from the show this
segment is brought to you by
better help that's better h-e-l-p
help and when you go to better
betterhelp dot com
slash griffin you will get a discount
being a roofing with griffin followers
so i really do encourage you to go get
some help if you need some help and even
if you're not someone who asked me
questions you're just watching right now
and you're like man i'm feeling a
certain way because a lot of people ask
me about the
you know they get questions about i have
a lot of anxiety anxiety uh
and they feel depressed and they feel
like they're they haven't found their
way
and and that's what this is all about
you know that's what better help is all
about right now you know so
you know it's like a lot of things
interfere with our life a lot of things
interfere with our happiness
and in in health and you go to account
like i say
therapy doesn't solve the problem for
you but they help you organize your
thoughts
they help you connect the dots they help
you realize that oh this is because of
something that happened in my childhood
or
they help you figure out like oh wow i
didn't realize i felt this way about
such and such
and that's what therapy does it helped
me tremendously you know just dealing
with boundary issues and dealing with
like
how do i deal with uh what's happening
with my mom and you know
dealing with the dementia and dealing
with my friend who's like a brother to
me dealing with his alcoholism and then
dealing with like this
having this new person in my life rachel
and like you know
you know am i am i ready for that and
just like really like
helping you focus and like i say connect
the dots to your feelings and emotions
and why they
affect your actions and and a place like
better health is gonna
really help you help you with that and
that's better help help
you know they're going to assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist this is
true professional therapy they connect
they connect you in a safe and private
online environment it's it's
convenient you could start communicating
with somebody in under 24 hours
that's how easy it is to set up and this
isn't like i say this is not self-help
this is professional counseling
you can send a message to your counselor
at any time 24 hours a day
and you'll get some timely thoughtful
responses which is what we want
you know you're going to get timely
thoughtful responses responses from
a professional counsel and it's all
without ever having to sit in some
uncomfortable
you know waiting room and that's the
part i tell you it's it's tough when you
know you're going to therapy because
there's a stigma to therapy and we have
we demonize it and you know
you when you're in that waiting room
you're looking around
you know and you're you might be
thinking oh man am i is this am i crazy
they looking at me funky and it's like
so you know better help it take it takes
a
it takes away that feeling because
you're going to be doing it in the
privacy of your own home
and i also do recommend when you do
therapy like this you know sit on your
couch sit in a chair
put the your laptop whatever you're
using set it on a table
you know some distance away from you and
set up the environment that like as if
you were going into an
office so you can really get the full
impact of it so
you know better help man they're
licensed professionals and they help you
with all the things that you guys
ask me about it's like depression stress
anxiety
relationships you know they're gonna
help you with trauma
you know anger issues even lgbt matters
if
if that's something that's going on in
your life and you have trouble you're
having trouble with your family
accepting you or you're having trouble
accepting yourself or dealing with any
kind of
issues of grief and self-esteem they're
here for you
everything is you share is confidential
obviously it's convenient it's
professional and most
importantly it's affordable okay
i want you to start living a happier
life
today as a listener you'll get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
at
betterhelp.com griffin
you got to go there join over 1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health
again everybody that's
betterhelphelp.com
and start living a better life today
all right so i did that one live in full
effect right here in front of you guys
uh you know i usually like to copy but i
thought you know i'm doing real world
advice from a grown-ass man and i want
uh
you guys to know that i got this new
sponsor and like i say i'm all about us
uh because this is tough times right now
we're living in tough times
it's difficult with the stay-at-home
order i'm in california so the
stay-at-home
own home order is tough we were just
starting to feel a little bit normal
going to these
outside restaurants and then that got
shut down so now we're back again and
we're thinking oh man when is this going
to change so
i get a lot of questions so here's our
questions of real world advice from a
grown-ass man
all right first up what is the most
impactful advice you can give to a man
in his 30s well
you know sometimes i hear a question
like this and i feel like the subtext of
this is
maybe you feel like you're not doing
enough i just got to my 30s and
you know you know what what's my life
right now am i do
and i'm just trying to tell you right
now it's never too late to start
anything
so my advice for you is to know that
it's not too late i just want you know
that i started
my professional comedy career and i'm
talking about
going to open mics and realizing that i
wanted to be a comic
and it started when i was 30 years old
so
you can do it if i can do it you can do
it so
just the thing you need to do right now
is focus
plan set goals and try to achieve them
you know and the thing is you have to
believe that you can do it
that was the hard part for me just
talking about myself right now is like
when i i know it was funny because
everybody kept telling me i was funny
but i believed that was funny
but can i be a professional comedian
that's the thing that held me back
for years but the moment i said to
myself
oh i can do this i will
but i had to believe it and when i did
believe it
i made it happen and i'm telling you
like in in in this all within reason
like if i said i'm going to be an
astronaut
no because i know deep down i can't be
an astronaut right
so what i'm saying is there is a moment
that you have with you and yourself
you and your whatever you believe in you
and your god
because you can't lie to yourself you
can't lie in your head
in your head when you know you can make
it
that's the moment when you believe you
can make it too not even just know you
can make it when you believe you can
make it
that starts to you know when you can
make it that's when
your life will change and it can happen
at any age
so that's my advice to you good luck
buddy next one
spent four years living with my now ex
feeling isolated and quarantined how do
i progress
well i mean that's like you know when
you live with somebody for four years
you have a familiarity you have a
there's this like homey feeling there's
this like comfortableness there's this
like
you have this like this rock even when
you even when a relationship is bad
at least they're there you know and and
that and having somebody having the
proximity of somebody around you
we don't realize how important that is
until it's gone
so right now i know you're feeling
isolated and you're missing that and
you're thinking oh man i wish that was
back
but it's just moving you got to move
forward look we're we're human beings we
adapt
to things it's the reason why we can
live in alaska and we can also live in
phoenix we can let you know because we
we're humans we can adapt we can adapt
physically and we also can adapt
emotional emotionally so that's what you
have to start doing
and i give this advice all the time
almost every time i do wearable advice
for a grown ass man it's time for you to
look after you
start working out start have setting up
hobbies start
trying to achieve those goals maybe it's
time to clean up maybe it's time to look
around your house and like
you know rearrange things it's time to
like really work
and focus on you now in the quarantine
right now and all this is going on it's
harder to meet people
but you know what that doesn't mean it's
impossible you know
people the dating apps are still
effective you go on instagram meet
people
start setting up zoom dates where you're
getting to know someone and i think
i listen i highly recommend that it's
it's so much better than just texting
someone for six months and then you
finally
meet them and you realize i don't really
like you even though you've built up
this expectation in your head
no get on the phone with them face time
do these zoom dates sit down and you
know on your couch they sit on yours and
you guys
try to get to know each other like that
make the effort
so that you feel isolated to make the
effort to not feel isolated by doing the
things that someone would do that's not
isolated you know
so connect reach out and good luck my
friend
good luck all right let me get my phone
goes dead cause i keep yapping too much
all right
next one what's a good way to get out of
a slump
and embrace your creative side well you
know it's like what is your motivation
to get creative
uh for for me it's always like when
let's see it's easier for me that's like
i shouldn't say that but it's just like
so i'm just in touch with like
flying off the handle so for me it's
like
when something happens like i remember i
saw the movie insidious
i remember the day i saw insidious that
movie scared the [ __ ] out of me
okay and i went to the comedy club after
that
and and i just went on stage and i
started talking about
scary movies and how that movie made me
feel and that turned into like a really
great bit of mine that i have on my half
hour special that i did on comedy
central
and where i talk about insidious and
it's just like one of those
just one of those bits that i really
love doing but it came from the
inspiration was
that thing that happened to me so what
is your inspiration for your art like
what do you like to write about what do
you like to draw about what do you like
to sculpt about what do you like to sing
about what do you like to
write poems about you know what inspires
you
you know art is inspired by living art
is inspired by the things around us
uh feeling things you know
and if you're feeling shitty right now
art is inspired from that too
taylor swift has made a whole career out
of feeling shitty
you know so i think that you just have
to you're only in a slump because
i think you forgot to live so i suggest
that you live
you know live and really document it in
your head
because you know art comes from some it
can come from the smallest things that
can come from the biggest things so
you just have to live and observe and
then you'll realize you're actually not
in a slump you just haven't noticed the
things that are right in front of your
face so good luck
a real good long time friend didn't
invite me to his wedding
is it bad that i felt kind of sad well
if it was recent
if it's recent i totally get it and we
should all be actually
be happy that we don't got to go to
somebody's dumb ass wedding right but
at the same time i totally understand
how you feel
i've experienced this myself you know i
have a bunch of comic friends that i
think are like really i thought
oh we're really good friends we're
really close and they've gone on to get
married and have
babies and have these really important
life uh achievements and things that
happen
and i didn't even get a call you know i
wasn't i was just a second thought
so i understand it's just you just have
to like you have to know
who you're who your like close friends
are
and it's okay if someone that you're not
in that person's immediate circle
you might know each other you know you
might even have good times together
but you know you just have to understand
that like not everyone
is as close to everyone that we think
sometimes it's just like this is a nice
relationship
but it doesn't go to the level of like
i'm spending money on a
a place setting at my wedding because my
wedding already thirty thousand dollars
because my wife want like you know to
invite everybody in her whole life you
know what i mean
it's like it's their party i totally get
why you feel the way you feel
and you should there's nothing wrong
with feeling like oh that kind of hurt
i thought we were closer but you have to
ask yourself does that
does that mean you're not close no it's
just that this is their special event
and they and they they have it in their
head how they want this party to go
and it doesn't necessarily you know mean
that they you know they don't like you
but i understand why you're feeling just
process your feelings and move on from
it and don't let it affect how you feel
about that person but i've been there
man
i totally have been there with this
exact same thing so
you just kind of go for me the way i
handled it i just was like oh okay well
i'm not as close to that person as i
thought
it's okay but then when i really started
to think about it i was like
well [ __ ] yeah we don't talk on the
phone that often we barely text each
other
i see him at the comedy club we've
traveled together but it doesn't mean
that we're like best friends
when you really start to evaluate your
friendships the ones that should invite
you to your wedding
they will you know but it's like
just because you've experienced a few
moments with someone it doesn't mean
that you're at
invited to the wedding level but
especially like i say now in covid
right now no one's going to weddings you
know and which is like great like i need
to marry rachel right now so that it
that'll be the cheapest wedding ever
because if i wait till everybody's got
the vaccine then it's like what
why are all these people here i don't
even like these people like that you
know
so i totally get it like i say just
process your feelings and and move on
from it and don't hold it against them
you know because they're going through
stuff too you're right you know what i
mean
all right buddy next one
do you ever compare hardships from the
past to hardships now
and tell yourself to suck it up yeah
and this is generational too though too
like it's like you know how you hear
your your parents will say like back in
my day we had to do this
and so but it's all relative to your own
experience and so as you get older
though
you start to look back and be like man i
remember when i thought that was tough
and you're like now you're dealing with
or you know or you're you're
or you're saying to yourself oh man i
really i remember how hard it was to do
a and now i'm sitting here and i'm
thinking that
what i'm doing now is just as hard as
that was
and you got to go oh no this isn't even
that hard it's just about it's just
about having like
you know use some common sense and and
uh you know
look within yourself and just have some
understanding of what you know what
you're all going through
it's all relative you know what i mean
you know what i'm saying just like
just look at yourself and just be like
be a realist you know he's like oh
you know what i i i am sitting pretty
right now and
so this isn't as hard as i thought it
was or it might be like oh wow
things used to be easy for me and
now i have to work a little harder it's
just assessing the
what's happening right now look at the
equation and try to figure it out
but you know i do i i have compared
i'll look i'll look back and remember
like trying to get on at open mics as
opposed to like trying to be a
a headliner at clubs you know you know
what struggle was
you know what was harder like trying to
pay bills while i was like trying to
like still
do comedy and stuff was like really hard
so now i think
you know when i'm sitting here and i'm
complaining about like you know
oh how come i couldn't do this i got you
know i couldn't get a window seat on the
thing or
man they're not flying me first class
and i'm thinking back in the day when i
had to drive like
you know i had to drive over a thousand
miles in three days
to like drive all over montana
to do comedy you know what i mean and
just complaining like well he's not even
gonna pay for my gas you know it's like
you know you know what i mean it's all
relative so yeah i do
i do compare sometimes and i do tell
myself hey suck it up
and and it's a good thing to check
yourself because that's really what
you're talking about is
check yourself before you wreck yourself
son so
good luck man here's another one guys
these are good ones today uh broke up
with my long-term girlfriend of four
years just over a month ago
any advice well i mean that's i i
you know you're leaving a lot of subtext
here like so i guess i have to read into
it like
do you miss her do you not miss her you
know what i mean are you
are you thinking because like you know
when you've been doing when you've been
with somebody for so long
you cut you get into a routine you know
you start
you know you you know you you eat
together you sleep together you
you know what i mean like you have like
it's a us situation it's always
us we're gonna go do this or you're
checking in like hey i'm gonna do this
is that okay with you and
so when that goes away now you have to
live your life as a single person and it
can be
it's a tough transition so again what i
always say
work on yourself work out eat better
organize
get some hobbies try to achieve some
goals set some goals
see where you are in life and be the
better version of yourself
that's what i suggest you do that's my
advice
but if you're sitting here thinking like
maybe i want to go back with her
it's always you know we always going to
feel that way you know with familiarity
of that person you are with and
you know you just have you have a
there's a special bond and connection
when you've been with someone that long
that you can't just throw away but
sometimes you got to make the choice
what's best for you what's best for her
so
you know take that into consideration
before you say
run back make sure i say
make sure you work on improving on
yourself so you're better
for you and for that relationship if you
go back
so good luck man
that's my advices you know look out for
you right now you know take care be a
better version of yourself so
for the next person or even for if you
end up
getting back with your ex can relate to
this one
my girlfriend is super messy
uh i'm living with her now how do i how
should i approach this without offending
well it is what it is you know
delicately
you know i says you just have to like
have like a talk you just go hey
i would appreciate if you'd help me with
this you know i don't i think that this
is
unacceptable for us to be have the
dishes like this all the time can you
help me with this you know you
you know you have to just talk with her
the way you would talk with her any when
you're trying to get anything
you know just with compassion with
delicacy with
you know uh taking her feelings into
account i mean
there's no need to fight about it
there's no need to bring you know fly
off the handle like
you messy [ __ ] no you're not gonna be
like that right you're just gonna be
like hey honey this is like really
do we really want to live like this can
can we can we work together and make
this a better
living space you know you you'll you'll
find your way man
you know her better than anyone knows
her so what's her likes and dislikes uh
what moves her what makes her feel
special what makes her
what makes her smile what makes her
angry you know all the triggers
so just stay away from those talk to her
with some compassion
don't make it about what she's doing
wrong make it about what you want it to
be
you know it's not about like hey you're
so messy it's about i would like to be
cleaner
it's not about hey you always leave
everything over there it's more like hey
it'd be great if we could be more
organized you know
it's all about how you approach it you
know don't blame her because that's what
she's going to feel bad about
you know because she knows she messy
they know they messy rachel's messy
i'm messy you know we're both messy so
that's why it works but sometimes i'm
like yo
you got to help me i'm not a maid you
know what i mean help me with this you
know
and she'll do it so you just have to
talk to her just talk to her and it's
gonna be fine
all right good luck
let's see this this last one guys last
one today and once again
uh you know this uh part of the episode
is brought to you by betterhelp that's
better help
help and go to their website
betterhelp.com
griffin and you'll get 10 off some real
counseling and if you need it go do it
because this is the times we're in right
now
it's affordable it's safe it's
convenient better help
all right last one advice on dating for
a single girl i'm ready to throw in the
towel
just real world advice i mean
i you know we always feel this way you
know first of all everybody has certain
expectations
of who they think they should they
should be with as opposed to who
is out there for you you know and so if
you're only looking for
you know a b and c and then you can't
find that
you're not realizing that that d e f g
like there's so many other
things out there so no i should i do not
say you throw in the towel
i just say you know you change your
expectations you know you just open
yourself
up to finding all kinds of different
types of people it's not settling it's
just opening yourself up to
different horizons you know what i mean
if you only date
one way like if you're someone that's
like you're always on tinder and you're
like i can't find anyone well get the
[ __ ] off tinder you know find
other ways there's other dating apps
there's you know you just gotta find
connections you know reach out to your
friends hey you know anybody single or
you know your people that know you maybe
they know someone and you know you just
got to like
put yourself out there and not think
that
because you haven't found it up to this
point that well that's it for you so i'm
gonna stop looking
and you don't have to look live live
your life
and you'll meet someone else who's
living their life and then your lives
are going to intertwine and you're going
to be like oh wow well here this person
is
you may have already met the person but
you wrote them off you know
so please you're not it's not over for
you
it's not you're you're gonna be fine
just work on you be the best version of
yourself
and then someone will be there
because you're gonna run into someone
because there's seven billion people on
the planet you can't help but do it
you know all right guys that's a short
but sweet
episode of riffing with griffin once
again
i want to thank our sponsor again
betterhelp that's betterhelphelp.com
griffin uh they're great so um i'm
actually giving me a discount too so i'm
gonna go check them out my damn stuff
i'll let you know how that goes but
i'm on twitch every single day eric
griffin gaming i put those videos up on
youtube eric griffin gaming my other
channel
and i'm always on twitch every single
day and make sure you check me out on
the potluck
on the crown channel on twitch and
that's
wednesdays at 8 pm eastern for the all
of december
so if this is your if you're catching up
and it's already like march and you're
like hey what episode is this maybe i'm
on
another a new show at this point right
now but for right now for you new people
that are watching in real time
the crown channel in december but once
again thanks for watching griffin with
griffin
i appreciate you guys here every week
all the comments and you know
i get a lot of great feedback doing this
show people hit me up about real estate
about
you know when i talk about something
they'll hit me up scientists will hit me
up about covid uh
trump people will hit me up about this
is what he's done right you know it's
like
i love all the interaction it's great
just come at me respectfully and uh we
can uh
we can move forward you know it's all
about how how we
treat each other treat each other with
respect and i'll interact with you
so thanks again for watching we're from
with griffin and i will see you next
week
you